well it's such a such a great great
[Music]
she's there everywhere um yeah I see
you've been familiarizing yourself with
our our obedience disk it's a little
invention of mine by the way
you know some people find it kind of
erotic what walk with me I'm gonna tell
you something obedience disk I've never
been crazy about that name I'm supposed
to be a placeholder until I can think of
something better every everybody started
to call him obedience I didn't hear
anything but weren't those like sparkles
out of your fingers like lightning maybe
really the cottage of cousin oh good
yeah there he is hey cuz we almost
couldn't couldn't find you what you've
been hiding hmm so admit what you did
Carlo what you said it was only a small
camels why did you do it as small camels
scambling gambling I don't know what
that means gambling with the camel oh
let's go camping
you said it was camping oh this no
survivor camping is bad but what you
really do I was gambling death blings Oh
gambling oh good hmm Carlo I pardon you
they do it again though right
officially officially pardoned from life
[Applause]